it's very unusual to have to build a
data management service where it could
be a blob store adjacent store a
relational database it could be anything
and it could be any one of many products
for each of those data structures and
yet you only want to have to build this
feature once and then have it run
successfully no matter what underlying
storage system you're plugging in you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen heusinger 40
years ago database research was an
exotic field and because of its business
data processing reputation was not
considered intellectually interesting in
academic circles but that didn't deter
dr. Phillip Bernstein now a
distinguished scientist in MSRs data
management exploration and mining group
and a pioneer in the field today dr.
Bernstein talks about his pioneering
work in databases over the years and
tells us all about Project Orleans a
distributed systems programming
framework that makes life easier for
programmers who aren't distributed
systems experts he also talks about the
future of database systems in a cloud
scale world and reveals where he finds
his research sweet spot along the
academic industrial spectrum that and
much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
Phil Bernstein welcome to the podcast
thank you
you're a distinguished scientist and a
bit of an OG at Microsoft Research and
you've been at the forefront of
innovation in database technology for
several decades but currently you're
working at MSR under the umbrella of the
data management exploration and mining
group or DMX before we dive deeper on
you and your specific work give us an
overview of DMX and how database
research is situated in the broader
framework of Microsoft Research today
well Microsoft has a huge database
business and the database business in
general from the very beginning in the
70s was largely driven by research and
so research has always been very
important ingredient in improving
database products this need to innovate
all the time and that comes both from
the engine side building the core
technology to manipulate large amounts
of data complex data but also the tools
to make it possible to design the
database to be able to manage it and the
DMX group covers both that covers base
engine technology for manipulating data
for building cloud services and then
also for tools to integrate data to find
ways to reduce the cost of ownership by
reducing the level of effort on the part
of database administrators so it's the
full range and that's where the data
management exploration being able to
look around and understand your data and
mining to really get into the tools to
analyze the data afterwards
well let's situate you now how would you
describe your research identity in terms
of what gets you excited about the work
you do and what gets you up in the
morning well I look for high impact I'm
trying to figure out what to work on
that's going to make a difference and
also where my incremental value is going
to be high because there aren't enough
people working on it or paying attention
to the problem
there are two technical areas where I've
focused mostly over the decades one is
transaction processing which is how to
build systems like online retail or
banking systems money transfer systems
those sorts of things net stuff is very
low level you're very deep into the
database engine and then on the flip
side much higher level the integration
of data so the data is in the database
you've got to manage it how do you tie
it together and I've worked on both and
I've kind of flip-flop back and forth
between them depending on the problem of
the day and where the short and medium
term opportunities tend to be well I
want to take it back for a minute cuz
you just mentioned a couple of topics
that I think are important you've done
some seminal work in transaction
processing and distributed databases so
let's go back several years give us a
snapshot of the computing landscape when
you started and then tell us what
changes you've seen over the years what
things look like for researchers in the
cloud era and why understanding the past
is helpful when innovating for the
future well it's been a long road I mean
I started my research in the mid-1970s
so it's over 40 years ago at that point
the database business was small it was
barely a business it was absolutely
disreputable as a research topic because
data management sounded like business
data processing which was believed to be
not intellectually interesting you're
writing COBOL programs and that was the
end of it and hardly any of the
fundamental issues had really been
explored at all and the ones that had
been explored certainly not in any depth
so the opportunities were everywhere and
in fact early in my career I I had to
stop working on some problems not
because they weren't interesting but
because there were just too many
problems to work on I had to had to
focus more in order to get something
done also those were the you know the
mainframe computers I mean there was no
did anything we knew it was coming but
it hadn't come yet database management
was all in a glass house and it was you
know glass enclosed air-conditioned room
used for business data processing period
no personal computers you know you talk
to people about working on computing and
that was considered very exotic I know
now everybody's got one and at least and
has a pretty good feel for what they all
do okay yeah it's really different okay
so when did you start seeing changes and
how did that impact what you were doing
as a researcher
they've always been changes so it's hard
to say that there was any given point
where the changes were really big I
started out looking at database design
for my PhD research but as soon as I
left and embarked on my own career I had
got involved in distributed databases
which seemed like one of the next big
things and I worked on it for many years
I stopped for a while and then with
cloud computing it all came back and I'm
working on it again so this is sort of a
pendulum these topics come and go
depending on what the workloads are that
are needed what the computing
environment is that has to support the
data management well the cloud presented
a massive jump in scale for distributed
systems writ large so you say you kind
of came back into it was it because hey
this is a big new nut to crack and I
want to be in on it certainly I wanted
to be in on it but I was also asked to
be in that job
it was Microsoft was starting to think
about changing its database strategy its
base products to work on commodity
hardware to scale out on large numbers
of inexpensive machines running in the
data center and that kind of looked
around and you know who is it that we
have on staff who knows something about
this and I was one of the people that
they tapped and so we have developed a
new strategy and it took many many years
for that to unfold this was back in 2006
so it's more than 15 years ago but where
we are now with the products we actually
landed roughly where
we were trying to get back from the
beginning so well okay so rounding out
this four part question that I kind of
just laid out and I'm still walking
through with you cuz I'm really
interested in this bill Buxton was on
the show and he talked about the long
nose of innovation and things come and
go and the idea that you can't innovate
for the future unless you really
understand the past so why from a
database perspective is understanding
the past helpful when you're trying to
innovate for the future the set of
mechanisms that we use to solve database
problems they don't change very fast
back in the early days we were learning
about certain based technologies for the
first time but now there's this
repertoire of ingredients that you put
into solving a database problem I'm very
sympathetic to graduate students who
were trying to learn this stuff because
you know I learned it slowly over a
period of many years as it was unfolding
but people getting into the field they
learned it in a very compressed amount
of time and they don't necessarily have
a deep understanding of why things are
the way they are and so when they
encounter a problem they're trying to
solve it just based on an understanding
of the problem and then trip over some
approach that they think oh I'll bet
that would be helpful but then they
don't realize this is actually a
variation on something that has been
applied in several other contexts before
[Music]
well let's get specific and talk about
some of your current work and there's a
project you've been working on called or
liens which you've called somewhat
generally a distributed systems
programming framework or a programming
model and runtime for building cloud
native services both a pretty high level
so tell us what is Orleans and what's
the motivation behind it or the pain
point that prompted it so maybe we
should start with what's a programming
framework so um it's a form of
middleware that is to say that it's
generic software it's not application
specific but it's not a low-level
platform either generally a framework
takes a bunch of services that are
available from operating systems
networking distributed systems and
packages them up to be easier to use by
integrating them in some nice way and so
Orleans is a programming framework
that's what it does is this integration
of lower-level services the problem it's
addressing is that of building
distributed applications that run in
data centers in the cloud on large
numbers of machines and the reason why
this is a problem is that mainstream
programmers who have learned how to
build applications are generally not
distributed systems experts and there
are many ways to go wrong when you try
to carve up an application and get it to
run on a lot of servers it needs to be
elastic that is to say without changing
the application you need to be able to
add servers if the workload increases or
reduce the number of servers if you
don't have so many customers using it it
needs to be reliable because these
machines are relatively inexpensive and
they actually fail at a significant rate
and so you don't want the whole thing to
come tumbling down every time you lose a
server so if you're gonna spread the
workload on multiple machines maybe you
don't do it so well and one of the
machines becomes a bottleneck it's sort
of the whole thing grinds to a halt
because this one machine is being
overtaxed so these are the kinds of
problems that an application developer
faces and Orleans is basically trying to
factor them out so that you don't have
to worry
about them at all the framework does all
that you just focus on building the
application all right so that's kind of
like the problem statement of why it
exists tell us how you would define it
maybe from a practical standpoint be
good to just mention the kinds of
applications that you would use it for
right and these are what are sometimes
characterized as stateful interactive
services what do I mean by that
well maybe easiest to see by example
Internet of Things games telemetry to
monitor some other system typically a
computer system social networking mobile
computing in all of these cases the
application is managing information
about something going on in the world
that's the main application function and
so the second characteristic is that
these applications are all object
oriented in the technical sense like
object oriented programming language in
Internet of Things the objects are well
they're things you know their sensors
their devices of various kinds in games
they might be things like players games
scoreboards and the like obviously for
mobile computing they're mobile devices
so in all these cases your application
that's running in the cloud has objects
that are surrogates or models of the
physical thing or logical thing in the
case of games that are out there in the
world and so what you're doing is the
application is spreading its workload
across servers by spreading the objects
around now if you want those objects to
be spread around on multiple servers
they better not share memory because
they may not be co-located on the same
server which means that the only way
they're going to be able to interact is
to send messages to each other and
another decision that was made in
Orleans is to have the objects be single
threaded that there's no internal
parallelism in these objects and the
reason for that is that programming in
that case is much more challenging for
application developers because now
you've got parallel activities that are
going
at the state of this object and they can
trip over each other and so they need to
synchronize and engineers historically
have a hard time getting that right
conceptually it doesn't sound that bad
but when you actually have to write
programs that run at high speed and they
access the shared state of the object it
actually is quite hard to get it right
in all cases so Orlean said no we're
just not going to allow that
so objects are single threaded and they
don't share memory and they communicate
by exchanging messages now what's new
and or leans is something called the
virtual actor model and the
characteristics that I just described of
single threading no shared memory
message based communication in the
technical literature that's often called
an actor it's just another word for
object that has these characteristics
and in the virtual actor model the
application developer does not control
when the object is instantiated when
it's activated where it's placed on
machines all of that is handled by the
framework what Orleans does in that case
is that it will first look around to see
if the object is running and if it is
then it will perform the function that
was requested if it's not running then
Orleans will pick a server on which to
activate the object will spin up the
object on that server and then we'll do
the invocation that was requested by the
application and we'll remember where the
objects located so that future calls can
go to that copy that's already running
if the object isn't used for a while
Orleans will notice that also and it
will deactivate the object and free up
its resources so it's sort of like a
paging system in operating systems where
you bring in pages of memory as needed
and then evict them when they're no
longer needed it's sort of the same
thing here but it's being done with
objects and this was a new concept when
Orleans was developed
and when exactly was Orleans developed
the project started things like 2008
2009 in there let's drill in a little
more technically you've alluded to
several of the things that I think are
important about the project itself and
then unpack some of the big challenges
you've addressed like scalability and
reliability in a cloud scale world
reliability and scalability are natural
consequences of the virtual actor model
so let's look at scalability remember
that if you invoke an object and it's
not running or liens will place it on a
server so it's up to Orleans to balance
the load across all these servers
ideally when you activate an object that
was not running you want to put it on a
lightly loaded server so that you don't
overload any other servers so Orleans is
in charge of keeping the load balanced
across the servers and that enables
scalability let's look at the
reliability part suppose the server
fails well obviously all the objects
that we're running on that server are
immediately gone
but the next time any of those objects
are invoked Orleans will recognize the
fact that they're not running anymore
and so it will just resurrect the object
that will just activate it on one of the
servers that is healthy it is running
and will continue making forward
progress so the application developer
doesn't have to be too concerned about
balancing the load across servers and
doesn't have to be worried about fault
tolerance which is something that
previous actor oriented systems all
exposed to the application developer
Orleans lets you forget about that but
there is one consequence of this which
is that when an object is activated what
state is it in you know what does it
know about itself and that is an
application programming problem because
at the moment that that server fails in
the objects go away their state in main
memory is lost and so when the object is
reactivate
on another server it's going to be
entirely up to the application program
for that object to reinitialize its
state and state is another word for data
and reading data to initialize an object
is just another way of saying it needs
to do data management and that's how I
got into this game once then I said gee
I think you folks could use some help
this is a pretty big burden on the
application developer to figure out how
to do all this state management we'll
talk about how this open source project
has evolved and grown over the last few
years
how have you added to the work and why
have you moved in those directions
well we've gained a lot by being open
source Orleans was one of the first
projects that went open source as I said
a little while ago I got into this
because I could see that application
developers had to do a lot of state
management and that the standard
abstractions that are part of the
database repertoire are relevant to
building these sorts of applications so
maybe I can just start adding them you
know add indexing add transactions add
geo distribution replication and just
make it easier for the application
developer I wasn't even sure if this was
research because it was just applying
what I knew about data management to yet
another product if you will but it
turned out that it was research which I
didn't really see going in and it's
research for two reasons one is that it
uses storage that's actually cloud
storage it's not storage that's running
on the server with the application
that's very unusual when you build a
data management system
you expect to be able to control storage
and ads in such an important ingredient
in doing data management but here the
storage is it's a service and the second
is because it's plug-in it can be
anything
again it's very unusual to have to build
a data management service where it could
be a blob store adjacent store a
relational database it could be anything
and it could be any one of many products
for each of those data structures and
yet you only want to have to build this
feature once and then have it run
successfully no matter what underlying
storage system you're plugging in and
that is a pretty unique challenge it's
not something I had ever seen done
before so it has required to rethink
these abstractions from the beginning
and so what if you what have you done
additionally or Wow have you new and
improved it as it were well take
transactions as an example when you
build a transaction system you have to
keep track of which transactions have
succeeded which is called committing the
transaction and which ones have not and
that's generally done in a log and that
log is in storage and the rate at which
you can run the transactions is heavily
dependent on the rate at which you can
record that information in the log so
it's a good idea to have one log and be
able to simply append these descriptions
of transactions that start and commit in
this log but there's a problem here
which is that cloud storage doesn't
offer a log and so every database system
I know of has a log and here we're gonna
implement transactions and there is no
log what are we supposed to do and you
know so we said well we got plenty of
storage so I guess we're gonna have to
do our own log on top of cloud storage
which is what we did and that worked but
it created some complexity in the system
that our customers didn't like very much
and we had to go back and do it again a
different way because they didn't really
want this custom log we had built
wristing and so what we did
was weary did it so that we managed this
state of the transaction
as part of the state of the object so we
piggyback our own log information on the
storage that's used by the object and
that was something we hadn't seen done
before it so how was that received they
liked it a lot that one's stuck and
that's what's shipping every research
project has at least one not yet and
putting that in air quotes probably a
lot more than one meaning things that we
don't support yet we can't do yet that
aren't on the map yet what are the open
problems that you still face in this
arena and how do you think you're
getting closer to or at least thinking
about getting closer to solving them
well one of the big things that we don't
do that we want to do is what's now
called serverless operation what that
means is that when you develop the
application and deploy it you're unaware
of the fact that there are many servers
out there that's not reality today with
Orleans because Orleans is simply a
programming framework and when you
develop your application you have to
explicitly reserve servers in Azure and
then deploy your application on those
servers so you're very much aware of the
fact that there are servers and they're
your servers you've reserved them to run
your application now what we'd like is
to have this be a serverless service
where you don't know about any servers
you still write your application in the
way you always have and you just drop it
in the in hopper and press a button and
our infrastructure on Azure then just
grabs that code and we take care of all
this server stuff of provisioning the
server and uploading the code to those
servers and deal with the failures and
add servers and reduce the number of
servers and all of that stuff in a way
that's completely transparent to the
person or the group that's running this
application operationally so serverless
operation is a big one
and the other is kind of related which
is just automating system management
capacity planning let's say you're a
game developer and you've got thousands
tens of thousands perhaps of gamers you
know playing just monitoring it figuring
out what's going wrong looking at the
behavior of the users right now that's
all part of the application and yet it's
something that every application
developer faces so why should everybody
have to do this in a custom way on their
own can't we do something
to automate it and then third is I mean
there's still data management
abstractions which are not built in to
Orleans that I would be interested in
adding someday you know we've added some
we've got transactions indexing geo
distribution are in there but there are
certainly others that we could add over
time depending on the need of the
applications and competing priorities
Phil you've been in every situation
along the research spectrum from
academia to Industrial Research to
product and back and in that sense
you're kind of a walking talking example
of human tech transfer yourself talk
about your experiences in each of these
areas and what the value is having had
experience in each of them as you've
landed here at Microsoft Research sure
well you know I have done all this other
work I was a professor I did a startup I
was working for a hardware company for
some years in product development and
now I'm in Industrial Research and a
software company but I've been at
Microsoft for 25 years so that says
something about which one I prefer but
let me talk about some of the common
features and all this work new ideas are
coins of the realm I mean your job is to
come up with new ideas to solve in other
cases to solve a problem that maybe
others have identified the highest
impact on this kind of work is generally
done in teams so you're always working
with other people customer pain points
are generally good motivation for
research partnerships are often worth
nurturing there are many activities that
you're required to do as a researcher
it's not just doing research but it's
also participating in the research
community it's writing research papers
it's reviewing research papers written
by others and everybody feels under time
pressure to do well at all of these
things and so learning how to align your
activities so they're all pointing at
the same goal are important so all that
is true for everybody but beyond that
academic research product development
and Industrial Research are different in
many ways
academic research tends to be
entrepreneurial that the professor is
generally running their own research
group that means your writing grant
proposals you're expected to teach there
are committees everybody's got to do
their share of committee work so it's a
very complex job
but when it works out well it's super
exciting it's really like running your
own company although you're doing it in
the context of a research group product
development is quite different and so is
industrial research because you end up
doing a larger fraction of the work
yourself in product development you're
writing specifications you're writing a
lot of code speed is a virtual you got
to be willing to live with the fact that
there's often insufficient time to do
the complete solution you want because
the products got to go out the door at a
certain time and if you're not ready
with your piece well the trains gonna
leave the station whether you're on
board or not and so in order to ship
products you have to learn how to steer
path to the right technical compromises
of what goes into the product and what
gets saved for the next version and when
you're in academia you don't have to do
that you know you just basically include
everything you want to include and you
know it doesn't have to be product
quality so it's okay on the other hand
shipping to a large audience is really a
kick I mean getting feedback from
grateful customers it's a unique
emotional experience that is really
wonderful when it all works and makes
working long hours super worthwhile
because you've really done something
that has an tangible effect in the world
now where does industrial research fit
in this you know it's somewhere in
between right it's research but you're
doing it in an industrial setting well
the main thing is that we have more time
we are not under the same time
constraints so we can actually work out
the details we have more control over
selecting our problems and so we can
identify problems maybe the product
group isn't even ready to think about
yet and as I said de-risk them you know
get it to the point where a product
group can pick it up and feel like they
can put it on a schedule and they know
how long it's going to take and have
lots of confidence that it's actually
going to work in the end
we talked about what gets you up in the
morning Phil but now it's the time on
the podcast where I ask what keeps you
up at night so what kinds of things keep
you up at night and what are you and
your colleagues doing about it
what I think about most is um am i
working on the right problem really
problem selections everything in
research if I solve it is it going to
have high impact is it likely to be
something that a product group is going
to pick up you know what is the barrier
to actually making it real maybe I
understand the nature of the problem
very well but I don't have any really
brilliant research idea on how to solve
it and sometimes I worry you know
whether I'm just too far ahead of my
time which is a unique thing about
industrial research you know we don't
tend to work on problems that the
product group can solve there every bit
as smart as we are and they have a lot
more people and so anything that they're
gonna do in the next couple of years
it's really not a good idea for us to
work on we have very little added value
and we don't really want to be working
on stuff that's 10 years out that's a
good thing in a university but you've
got to pay the bills so we tend to work
in this 2 to 5 year range and there are
times that I just get it wrong I just I
think this is going to be an important
thing four or five years from now and
two years into it it still seems like
it's gonna be four or five years and
it's just the goalposts keep moving out
and I think maybe this was not the ideal
place to be so that's probably the
biggest thing that I worry about outside
of doing the work itself you have a long
and varied path in high tech we've
alluded to it a bit in our conversation
but I'd love to hear your story tell us
about your roots your journey and your
ultimate path you know give us the
Reader's Digest version is Reader's
Digest even a thing anymore
enough to know version sure and it
really is a journey and when I look back
on there are so many Forks in the road
where if I had taken the other path it
would have turned out very differently
and I have no idea how so I got a PhD in
computer science and I had a choice
between a research lab and a university
I went to a university I became a
professor at Harvard that all sounds
very impressive except that at the time
Harvard's computer science department
was not very good and so it's um it was
made it good fell it was it was
impressive to people in the real world
but in the computer science world was
like why would you go there and I had
done a lot of consulting on the side
partly to enrich my understanding of
real problems and partly because
universities don't pay very well and
that led to a gig with a start-up doing
a computer development and they
ultimately offered me to be in charge of
their whole software operation and so I
left academia I became vice president as
startup for two years and after about a
year and a half I decided I really hated
it and that was not the right place for
me and I actually went back to a
university for a couple years completed
some research that I had been doing
before that sojourn at a start-up and
then they shut down the university which
is a bit of a shock but it was the
startup university it was called Wang
Institute of Graduate Studies it was
goal was to create a professional degree
program in software engineering which is
still a very good idea much like you
know law school versus a philosophy
department or medical school versus a
biology department anyway I had to go do
something else so I went to work for
hardware company Digital Equipment
Corporation and worked on their
transaction processing products for a
while and then their middleware for data
integration for a while and then they
started unraveling and seemed to have a
history of this that and I don't think I
was a cause but because of this work I
had done on metadata management and
integration I got a call from Microsoft
to be architect for the development that
they were doing in this area Microsoft
repository and so I took it and that's
what brought me to Microsoft
I worked in that product for four years
at which point it became clear to me
that there were just other things that
company thought were more important and
so I moved back into research and that's
where I've been ever since I knew an
East Coast kid I grew up on the East
Coast you know in New York and then went
to school in Canada and University of
Toronto and then and then after that I
moved to Boston and I had this long
string of jobs in Boston Harvard the
startup back to another university then
Digital Equipment Corporation so all
saving in the same place he did the big
jump to the West Coast by Microsoft yeah
tell us something we don't know about
you I've been asking this in the context
of whether it's a personal trait or a
defining life moment that may have
influenced a career in research but if
I'm honest I actually just want to know
what goes on in the lives of researchers
outside the lab so however you want to
answer it Phil something about me that
you wouldn't ordinarily know I am
fascinated by finance investing now you
might think that oh boy he really likes
to make a lot of money and I'd love to
make a lot of money I'm actually really
bad at it I mean it's like I don't
manage my own savings and delegate that
to a professional but what I like about
it it's endlessly complex it's always
changing and there's one success metric
there's no way to fake it if you're
making money or you're not so I'm just
totally hooked I mean I read a lot about
it and it's a hobby I got no really
personal benefit my wife makes a joke
that I sound very good
you know people asked me about
investments and I sound extremely
knowledgeable and all and then she looks
at me and she says but how come you
can't make any money well you know you
can't have everything well Phil it's
time to wrap up before we go I want to
give you a chance to offer some parting
advice to our listeners and many of them
are just getting started on their path
to high tech research and you're a
veteran in the field so you're in a
unique position to impart some wisdom
knowing what you know and having done
what you've done over the course of your
career what thoughts would you share
with our audience I'll give you a lot
thanks for the opportunity I actually
have strong opinions on this one I think
the most important thing is to know what
you're optimizing and I think there are
only four possibilities money power Fame
or personal happiness now everybody
wants all four but if you don't
prioritize one of them over the others
you might not get any of them at the
level that you really want there'll be
many Forks in the road along the way and
if every time you face that fork in the
road you choose based on a different
optimization criterion you're lowering
the chances that you're gonna get the
one that you want most but beyond that
there are many other little snippets of
advice I'll try to do them quickly early
in your career choose your research area
for the long term it's so easy to pick
something because it's a hot topic but
if you want to succeed in a big way you
want to be an expert it's something
that's going to be super important 15
years from now when you've gotten past
that apprentice journeyman stage you're
now considered to be an expert and now
this thing is super important and you've
had 15 years to really become one of the
best people working in that area so
choose a topic where you're incremental
value is higher which means probably
it's going to be an unpopular topic
which means you have to be brave exploit
what you're good at but also work around
what you're not good at and look for
opportunities to grow also you want to
exploit synergies with your environment
based on what's around you you can get
research leverage from the fact that
your company is really good at a certain
something and therefore you have a
competitive edge in working in that area
but despite all of this you still want
to be flexible opportunities will show
up randomly and that may turn out to be
the most important thing in terms of
your long-term success is that you
grabbed the right opportunity at the
right time which might have been leaving
behind something you had actually
invested quite a bit of time and
and then finally a piece of advice I got
very early in my career as a researcher
which is if you want to be good
write a lot of research papers if you
want to be great never publish a weak
one because you want people when they
see your name on a paper they want to
say oh his or her papers are always
super interesting I got to read this one
if only every third paper you write is
like that much less likely to get their
attention I'll stop there I could stay
here for a long time because you're
giving me some advice that I could use
sir great Phil Bernstein thank you for
coming on my pleasure thank you Richie
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Phillip
Bernstein and the latest research in
database management exploration and
mining visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]